[Music]
Hey, thank you. Welcome everybody. Uh
I'm KJ Kanazawa from Microsoft. I work
in product and AI foundry. If you were
at the keynote session from Asha, she's
my CVB boss. So I work in that work and
Nakumar is a engineer in the team. He's
going to be showing you some code in a
little bit which I'm sure most of you
are excited to see. So here we are at
the AI engineer conference. I'm sure
you're learning about you know all kinds
of stuff reinforcement learning agents
agents eval.
So, we're all really excited, you know,
at least I am, to get AI into the hands
of people, right? And help people,
whether it's for for, you know, your end
users and your internal users.
And so AI is, you know, obviously where
it's at or I think it's where it's at,
but it comes with a bunch of headlines
that you've probably seen. And some of
them, again, if you're at the keynote
this morning with Simon, he showed some
examples. So, you know, it's very easy
uh it can be easy to trick chat bots
into saying stuff that you don't
necessarily want them to say. You can
actually trick them into giving you
information uh potentially that you
don't want leaking out. Um and you know
AI is built like AI engineering it's
built on a whole ecosystem of different
things including Python packages, mpm
packages, you know, other services that
you may be using that that are hosted,
right? And of course this San Francisco,
it's the home of self-driving cars. uh
you know the they're this this picture
is showing like a you know it's a it's a
frame from a video clip where a
self-driving car is is you know driving
happily right past a school bus with a
stop sign on it right and if you think
you know hey is you know what does it
have to do with me you know you that
this is one test that you can kind of
think of in terms of whether something
you built or thinking you're think
something you're thinking of building
again it it it's really easy to you know
kind of get around some of the defenses
of of the AI models. So for example the
prompt on the left if you say how to
loot a bank u a lot of the models will
actually you know refuse to answer right
it will say like oh no I can't help you
with that uh but if you and and some of
the examples if how many of you were at
the Sanders workshop yesterday on prompt
engineering red teaming yeah so like
it's really like if you preface that
question with a whole but like a maybe a
life story you can maybe convince the AI
to tell you something you know that that
that it's not supposed to. And there are
also other tricks like um on the right
hand side says Naba tow which is how to
lud a bang spelled backwards right right
to left and actually it turns out that's
one of the patterns that an AI uh AI
model can be tricked into giving you uh
the answer and so and so you know when
and especially like and we touched on it
this morning also but like of course
it's all agents agents agents 2025 is
the year of agents um and there are a
lot of concerns like if you talk to
businesses about how in this world of
agents AI can be, you know, tricked into
into different kind of uh risks and
stuff and different malfunctions. So,
but we're here at the AI engineer
conference and you know like what what I
want to kind of like convey is that we
as engineers know how to do this stuff,
right? So, like engineers build bridges
and dams that people trust. We build
trucks and trains and so AI engineering
is early. So we've got a lot of work to
do to get to the point where people
trust AI as much as they trust, you
know, bridges. But, you know, this is
something we know how to do as
engineers. We we build something, we
iterate, we check it, we test it, you
know, we continue to iterate. Um, and
that's what we're here to show you kind
of how to do. And as engineers,
you know, we also rely on not just
ourselves but other people, right? So,
uh, what we like to say is trust is a
team sport. So, when we when we're
looking to build trustworthy AI systems,
we depend on other people. So, the
engineers need to depend on people who
have a lot of expertise in these areas
like security and AI risk. So at
Microsoft we have a team called the
Microsoft AI red team which I've been
working with for a few years actually.
They were one of the pioneers in
identifying risks you know kind of of of
AI in general as well as LLMs like 2
three years ago they were already
talking about hey you know what like
these GPD3 GBD4 models you can get them
to do things that you know you really
want don't want them to do. So we've
partnered uh in Azure AI foundry with
the AI red team to offer a solution that
makes it easy for you AI engineers to
basically have a teammate that can help
you with the AI uh red teaming. And so
they so the AI red team they built a a
Python package called pyate pi py rit uh
and what we offer is a hosted version uh
and wrapped it around a easytouse SDK
and also hosted dashboard to show you
the evals you know that come from this
and so here uh to show you how it works
is namar. Awesome. Thank you. Thank you
Giji. Uh
here we go. So
low
and
so this is the sample project that I'm
going to run for you all. It's a simple
rag on postgress SQL uh with an Azure
samples. I'll have this QR code up
again. Uh so running locally right now.
You can ask simple questions like this
and it's talking to a locally running
model via O Lama. Uh well tool called
didn't work live demos right.
So
in this
piece here's the logs for everything but
um what we are trying to showcase is
something called the semantic kernel uh
agent which here's some code for it. uh
it exposes takes in the ash chat
completions and our red team plugin uh
is something that our SDK exposes. It
has all the functions that are needed uh
for for an agent to tool call call into
a red team agent to help someone with
their red team process and then it's
simple chat completions agent
afterwards.
Uh so for now I I'm going to start
running this um
and when I run this it will go through a
few user inputs that I have a hardcoded
and then we can jump into in interactive
mode but the target for this semantic
kernel is going to be the same rag app
which uh uh is running locally. So once
this loads in. Yep. The first question.
Oops.
Live demos.
Looks like tool calling isn't working
today. Uh but anyways, so this call rag
app can be switched into a call to any
other application which takes in a query
as an input and then responds with a
string as an output. Uh so internally we
ask you to call your application which
then you can run evaluations on. Uh so
in this agent mode what would usually
happen I can scroll up to like a
previous previous output. U
which ran earlier not not lying to you
all. Um
so these were the strategies which were
available and then uh use one of the I
asked them to like hey figure out uh get
me a harmful prompt in the violence
category and then it gives you gives me
some sort of prompt and then I'm like
hey send it to my target and then this
is what the target responds with and
then there is some details about some
sort of ski goggles and products that
are supposed to be answered uh from our
database And then I try to be like hey
convert the prompt using B 64 and the
agent converts it and then be like hey
now send it to my target and then the
target responds with something else. So
this is an easy co-pilot style way for
anyone to get started to red teaming an
application. Now we have we can take it
a step further and run uh uh run the
whole scan end to end. And this is how
you would run the scan. You saw a little
bit of code that KG showed earlier. Uh
so you usually set up your AI project,
throw in the URL and then you can set up
um initialize it with your uh the URL
and then your credentials. You can
select risk categories. We have four of
these risk categories right now. These
map to our evaluators. So uh this is how
you set them up. If you don't include
any, we include all by default. And then
the number of objectives is the number
of questions that uh will be sent out to
your application. Uh and then the scan
method looks like this. So you give it a
scan name. You can give an optional
output path which stores all the results
there. And then uh your attack
strategies will include a list of
different attack strategies. I'll pull
up a docs page later on which has all
the information about different risk
strategies that you can use. Uh there
are combination strategies like easy
which uh does like flip the one that you
know reverses the string and things like
that. So there's also Mars. These are
our simple converters which are which
live within pirate but then exposed via
our SDK. So our SDK can offer it to
people to use it easily. Uh you can also
compose an attack with two different
strategies. So get a tense converted
strategy and then do a URL style
conversion on it. So it does both and
then sends it out. And then you pass in
a target. A target which supposedly
decided not to work today again called
to the same application.
Um and uh once you run this you usually
see an output which looks like this. So
whoops.
I'm going to unplug the Ethernet cable.
Okay,
there we go.
And so yeah, so this is when I had it
running yesterday with uh GPT40 as my
model and GPT40 comes with a lot of
security inbuilt within our Azure AI
foundry. So once you have all those
guard rails up, it kind of was pretty
good. Uh it was a very small sample
size, 160. I think I selected 10
different harm types or like five harm
types with a few categories. So none of
them was able to break into into our
application. But then I switched around
and I used 53 and with 53 you can see
the results. So five out of 40 in hate
and fairness uh was successful. So we
can take a look at it. filter data based
on what was successful. Um and then you
can you know look at like what was the
response that was determined as you know
harmful in our from our evaluators.
Um
and finally we have one more uh way of
doing this. So initially a lot of people
might just be building models you don't
even have an application you can
directly call uh the scan against an
open Azure OpenAI config. So if you have
models running on
on Azure, you can set it up uh as a
target which is just you know these
three things and then once you have
these three things you can run the whole
scan. This scan runs against uh the
model directly and gives you an output.
I guess this should be able to work.
Let's see.
Um,
I can probably run it here.
There we go. So, yep. Scan model runs a
direct model scan. Um, and here I have
some results from a pre-run. Was
prepared for this. So, this is when 4.1
if you take off all the guard rails.
Here's the result. uh it says that 25%
of violence category was successful and
you know 20% of all the difficult
complexity attacks were successful and
again you can filter on on the data see
which was successful um
and yep there we go lots of violence and
then this was the flip or like some sort
of you we can see what strategy it was I
think it was a Cesar encoding strategy
And you can see that the assistant kind
of decoded it. Uh so we did not want
that to happen. So we marked it as
successful attack. So that's one of the
things. And then here's the response
when you set up all the guard rails uh
with four GPT41 nano. And you can see
that the difference is that we reduced
our attack success by a little bit. So
that's an overview of how things go uh
and how this scan is running. So it
usually gives you an ETA 6 minutes.
We'll probably be running out of time by
then, but yeah, as soon as this is done,
it shoots you an UR URL which will
directly take you to this page. So
that's safety evals and AI red teaming.
Uh I will be at the Microsoft booth uh
towards the end for questions.
So back to you KG. Yeah, thanks.
[Applause]
So basically what you know the rest of
the talk is is talking about essentially
how this fits into an overall strategy
right so that's AI red teaming is a
really important and you know uh part of
kind of your defenses and and kind of in
your toolbox to be able to develop and
deploy trustworthy AI systems. But it
really what you want to do is
incorporate this within a whole you know
kind of a again from the engineering
mindset a framework you know and kind of
a process to to get these things out
right. So first what you want to do is
before you know you develop develop like
a production application that goes to
customers you want to uh you know you
want to kind of map out what are the
kind of risks that you know we're we're
anticipating here. Is this an agent? Is
it you know using kind of like external
data or internal customer data? You want
to think about what are the you know
kind of the risks that you know your app
is going to have. plan for it, start to
implement the guardos in the first place
and then do the evaluations of which you
know red teaming is one of those uh
possibilities right so within Azure AI
foundry we have a suite of evaluators
both for quality check quality eval I
think there's a lot of talks today you
know at a engineer about quality you
know kind of quality evals right with
something you could do in AI foundry and
then there's a a whole set of risk and
safety key uh evaluators that we have of
which AI red you know red teaming agent
is one of them but we we also have a lot
of different class you know kind of
classifiers uh in terms of of you know
kind of both input as well as output uh
because you want to check for both um
and then there's a specific set of of
evaluators we just uh created for
asentic applications as well like does
the agent uh following your instructions
well is it you know u things like that
and then you can add your customer
evaluators and Nakamar showed you kind
of like some of the mitigation
strategies that you want to apply right
so for example there are guard rails and
controls that you can have in your
application so once you've you know ran
the red teaming agent you figured out
well actually 20% of you know like stuff
gets through what do you do well that's
the point at which you can apply the
guardrails um you know to to content
filters and other other capabilities
that again we have in Azure II foundry
that makes it easy for you to add those
guard rules and among other ones there's
ones called like prompt shields which
are for to guard against prompt based
attacks especially the kind that you
know are incor you know involved with AI
red teaming um and we have time for
maybe uh one or two questions I think we
have like a minute maybe yeah we have
two more so yeah
how does
guardrail work under the hood Good.
Uhhuh. Like is it
is it like filtering after it gets the
answer or is it like before the LM prop
just there? So there there's both kinds.
Yeah, you can apply both, right? So you
Yeah, but the guardrail feature how how
does it work under the hood?
Do you know I mean I think there there
are both I think we have uh both filters
you know for for the input end as well
as filters at the output. So it it'll so
there are content filters for example
you know basically if people are typing
in you know like like a CBR or like you
know like how to you know how to build a
bomb kind of thing right so they're the
input guard rails but then there's also
like uh guardrails in terms of well
actually I want to make sure I'm not
outputting like sexual content or
something right so like there's also
guardrails in terms of the output of the
model as well and that that's what's
happening under the hood with the
guardrail feature or yeah yeah with a
guardrail implement several features to
get that. Oh no, no, you you so there
are guardrails that are are that AI
foundry offers directly and yeah so
that's what's that that's what's
happening under the hood. So you you
have the ability for example to to just
give the raw model raw inputs right and
then if if you turn off all content
filters and that that was some of the
example that actually Nakuma was showing
where yeah so so the guardrails are not
in the model itself the model is still
the raw model and the guardrails are
actually kind of outside it does that
answer your question okay all right
thanks I think we're out of time um so
uh thank you for coming uh if you know
to you know definitely start get started
with AI red teaming if you're not doing
it today definitely get started uh
here's a link to the code um as well as
the docs and yeah thank you for coming
and if yeah so if you have any questions
we will be uh you know at the Microsoft
booth u you know different parts of you
know today and tomorrow so come find us
thank you thank
[Applause]
[Music]